is now what is scarier after shooting uh
miss Bala Mexican drug cartels or beauty
pageants I mean I cannot say anything
bad about beauty pageants because then
the entirety of photo Ricans would be
against me it's fair enough they both
seem equally terrified I mean of course
I have my opinions about both I think
yeah I mean I think Puerto Rica it's
like are very proud of their beauty
pageants so drug cartels maybe so Lindo
your character is a mexican-american who
was deported from California to young
age and ended up as a cartel leader at
the border of Mexico but I think
something I found really interesting
about him I'm not sure other people are
getting is that his name actually rhymes
with mando you really made you made that
stretch so who goes harder Sesame Street
or Mis bolas
I mean I think they go hard in two
different ways I dig I spoken about this
before that you know what the worked I
was able to do ssme Street was something
very important and was something
actually very radical and and and
beautiful and introducing certain
aspects and of identity and
communication and and and doing what you
could with what you had and I think this
character shares a lot of those traits
of course in a completely different
aspect and context not to marry them
both in any type of narrative but it's
also a person that is like trying to
make do and and with whatever set of
circumstances there are so they both go
hard and with very different outcomes
let's see a crossover one day um I don't
think there's actually been a rise of
portrayal like very nuanced portrayals
of Mexican cartel members and shows like
my anism Breaking Bad and narcos did you
watch anything for inspiration or did
you study up on a character like Lindo
how did you lino Leano I'm sorry I'm
sorry
Linda's pretty maybe that's why I got
confused
I did do research on the actual cartels
I don't tend to over research certain
characters in terms of what other people
have done just just to give them and
myself an opportunity to organically
find them and I think a lot of the
nuance comes from trusting that what I
how I experience them and how I portray
them is enough you know so everybody has
that every actor has their own process
but mine I I try not to because some of
those performances are so good that even
if you watch them they date they stay on
you so I didn't do that that side of it
all I found like the relationship
between lino Leano and Gloria it's like
so upsetting and I think that's because
it was so charged there was a real
chemistry in connection between you two
but you are it is a very weird dynamic
is that something you guys talked about
her how do you approach that kind of
character who is both holding someone in
hostage but also having a connection
with them I think the connection that
people see comes from the fact that they
see there's a point in the movie that
that you see that they're they respect
each other and that they know that each
other will do whatever it takes to
survive and I think we see that in the
film and I think that people are
identifying themselves with that and I
think that's where our connection comes
from because on-screen those characters
are doing that and Gina Rodriguez and a
smile acoustic or the off-screen are
doing that as well we're really trying
to push and be successful and we have a
mission with what we do and we recognize
that in each other and we're very proud
of each other and I we respect each
other in that sense as well oh it was a
great performance and I love seeing it
thank you
you